BRUNO AZIZA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Bruno Aziza.
And today, I'm sitting
down with Polong.
Now, you know Polong because
you might have picked up
on the content he's built for
product recommendation design
patterns.
What are design patterns?
They are solutions that
help you assemble technology
to solve a business problem.
And Polong is at it
again, because this week,
we're releasing a new design
pattern for demand forecasting.
So we're going to talk
about what that is,
how you can use it precisely.
Polong, thank you so
much for giving us
some time this morning, in fact,
this afternoon, because you
live in London,
where you guys just
had a snow storm,
gigantic snow storm.
And I think you know how to
deal with that because you're
originally from Toronto, right?
POLONG LIN: Yeah, that's right.
It's kind of quite
cold here in London.
And it's reminiscent
of my time back
where I grew up in Toronto.
So it's kind of funny to see
the car struggling a little bit
here in London-- kind of
reminds me of how rare it
is to see snow fall in London.
BRUNO AZIZA: Well, hopefully,
you're staying safe at home.
And thanks for the work that
you're doing for these design
patterns.
Let's get into it.
Tell us a little bit
more about why you
decided to pick this pattern.
POLONG LIN: Absolutely.
So this pattern is all
around demand forecasting.
And so whether you're a
consumer or business today,
and no matter where
you are in the world,
you could go to a store, let's
say, hoping to make brownies,
and then realize that they're
out of chocolate powder, cocoa
powder.
And then, meanwhile, you
look in the grocery aisle,
and you see sacks of potatoes.
And they're starting
to turn green.
They're starting to turn bad.
And this is kind of like the
essence of demand forecasting,
is when businesses can try to
anticipate or sometimes not do
well in anticipating the
demands of the consumers.
So in the case of
chocolate powder, maybe
there wasn't enough
chocolate powder.
They didn't quite
anticipate the demand
during this particular season
or particular day of the year.
Whereas for potatoes,
they had a surplus.
And so they had too
much of something.
And so demand
forecasting is all about
trying to anticipate the
right amount of, let's say,
product or item
that you might need,
or resources that
you might need.
So you really try to
save money on things
that you don't need to overly
supply, while at the same time
dedicating more of those
resources towards things
that you can anticipate will
have much higher demand,
essentially.
BRUNO AZIZA: Typical
demand-and-supply problem.
And I'm sure people are very
familiar with this problem
in retail.
But this is also appropriate
for other industries, right?
POLONG LIN: Yeah, absolutely.
There is, for example, energy.
Energy providers have to try
to predict how much energy they
need to prepare on an
hourly basis, I assume.
And there's obviously
daily cycles.
So during the day versus
during the evening,
people use energy
differently, their electricity
at home differently
when they're cooking
versus when they're outside,
or, I guess, nowadays, when most
people are at home as well.
And then there's
also seasonal cycles,
because when it gets colder,
like it is now here in London,
people may tend to use a
little bit more energy.
So energy providers have
to really think about that.
And it's not just about energy
that could be mobile apps
or telecom or online
gaming services,
where if you have
a lot of users,
and they suddenly
come to your service
because the holidays or
a weekend or something,
and you don't have the right
resources allocated in place,
that could disrupt the
service for everyone.
So it's not just not being
able to make brownies.
It's, no one can make brownies.
No one can enjoy brownies.
Or essentially, translating it
back to that but your domain,
no one can enjoy the service
because, let's say, the servers
are down.
And so for that reason,
demand forecasting
can really span across
lots of industries
and be really impactful to
the end consumer as well.
BRUNO AZIZA: So very relevant
to retail, of course,
energy, telco.
But this problem of
demand and supply
is present across
the entire economy.
And that's why,
with this solution,
we know we're going to
help many, many customers.
In fact, a lot of these
design patterns-- they
originate from customer demand.
So tell us a little
bit about how
this is going to impact
the customer deployment
and how you've seen
this in action.
POLONG LIN: Yeah, absolutely.
So you can do demand
forecasting today
in a variety of different ways.
You could use different kinds
of technologies and softwares
and programming languages.
This demand forecasting
pattern focuses
on using, training, deploying
demand forecasting models
with BigQuery ML.
And so if you think about,
to kind of take a step back
and think about how it machine
learning models typically
get used in production,
traditionally, a business
may have their data in,
let's say, a data warehouse.
And they often end up extracting
that data out of the data
warehouse to train and deploy
the machine learning models.
But this can run into
some difficulties.
So if you're extracting data
from a data warehouse, number
one, that's a data
governance issue sometimes.
If you have any sort of PII data
coming out of a data warehouse,
you now have to track where all
your data is going and worrying
about data leakage.
That's one thing.
And then the second
thing is around
provisioning the right resources
to train your machine learning
model and finding a place to
host your machine learning
model as well, trying to deploy
your machine learning model.
And these are all complexities
that can really bog down
a machine learning pipeline.
It can make things quite a
bit longer or more complex
for you to go from zero to a
fully productionized machine
learning pipeline very quickly.
And that's where BigQuery
ML really fills in this gap.
So BigQuery, which is a fully
managed, serverless data
warehouse-- you know, you
have your data storage,
let's say, all your
transactional data directly
in BigQuery.
You could do your
analytics also in BigQuery,
and it's very easy to do so.
And now with
BigQuery ML, you can
do all your machine
learning workloads,
train and deploy your machine
learning models directly
with BigQuery ML.
So you have this kind of
all-in-one sort of thing.
By that nature,
it means you don't
have to worry about
data governance,
and you don't have to
worry about finding
some extra infrastructure,
exporting, finding
some other service to be able
to train and deploy your models.
So that's where BigQuery ML
fits into demand forecasting--
making things a lot easier for
customers who go from months
to creating a machine
learning pipeline down to,
let's say, weeks, or
weeks down to days.
So an order of magnitude
faster by using BigQuery ML.
BRUNO AZIZA: So you have the
benefits of the governance
issues you don't
have to worry about,
and the time to
market, if you will,
because data doesn't
have to move.
It's integrated
into the same suite.
That's a great overview.
Tell us-- if I'm
listening to you,
and I want to start
using this pattern,
what do I do next here?
POLONG LIN: Absolutely.
So you can explore the
pattern, and Bruno will point
to this outside of the video.
But the pattern will essentially
give you a bit of a quick start
into figuring how to do this
in your own environments
very quickly.
So starting off with the
sample retail data set
that you can replace
with your own data set--
so we have this
sample to start with,
and then essentially
showing you how
to train that model
with BigQuery ML.
This is a time series
demand forecasting model
that you'd be using
with BigQuery ML.
It's very easy, just not
too many lines of code.
And you have a model.
And then number 3, then
how to make your forecasts
once the model is trained
within BigQuery ML.
And again, this is
all within BigQuery.
You don't have to exit
the ecosystem at all.
And then finally, once
you have your models,
you have your
forecast maybe running
on a daily, weekly
basis, you also
want to make sure your models
are updated and staying fresh
so that with new data
coming in, you're constantly
updating the models
that you really
can forecast and
anticipate demand based off
of recent data.
So I show you how to do
that in the pattern as well.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's fantastic.
Well, thank you so much, Polong,
for taking us through it today.
Thank you so much for
the hard work you've
put into these design patterns.
If you're listening to
us, and you're interested,
make sure you click on the
link down below to get started.
And of course, I hope that
you can reach out to Polong
as well if you have specific
issues at your account level
and you want help.
We're here to help.
That's what these
resources are for.
Polong, thank you so
much for the time today.
I'll talk to you soon.
POLONG LIN: Thank you.
Take care.